[Musique]
et de la Coupe du monde de football on
en parle encore un petit peu avec vous
Michael et elmidoro qui est revenu en
plateau la France fera son entrée demain
dans cette Coupe du Monde ce mardi 22
novembre ce sera à 20h face à
l'Australie quels sont les communes dans
les Yvelines qui vont diffuser ce match
vous le savez c'est un grand débat
depuis plusieurs semaines certaines
communes ne veulent pas diffuser les
matchs de la Coupe du Monde aussi nos
protestations contre l'organisation
Qatar les municipalités de trappes et
Andrésy ont par exemple décidé de ne pas
installer d'écran géants de diffuser les
matchs mais si on regarde bien très peu
de communes vont organiser un événement
autour de ce premier match des Bleus
j'ai trouvé seulement 4 villes dans le
département qui auront annoncé sur leur
site internet l'organisation d'une
soirée football pour voir ce premier
match des Bleus le paier en Yvelines
dans la salle des fêtes de la mare aux
loups Bois-d'Arcy à la Fabrique Bailly à
l'espace Robert Thierry enfin
Triel-sur-Seine au Cosec c'est très peu
quand on pense aller faire les sens
autour du premier match des Bleus lors
de la Coupe du Monde 2018 on s'en
souvient bien sûr avec la victoire des
Bleus en plus en finale dans un de ce
tournoi international de tennis fauteuil
qui a lieu cette semaine à Feucherolles
mais d'abord les résultats sportifs du
weekend et on continue avec du football
justement on jouait ce weekend en coupe
des Yvelines lors de ce troisième tour
et en cours recevait l'équipe 2 de où et
qui évolue une division au-dessus malgré
une belle prestation des élans courtois
se sont finalement les joueurs du nord
du département qui se sont qualifiés le
résumé du match regardez il est en cours
contre Houilles une division d'écart
deux équipes pour un objectif se
qualifier en 8e de finale de la Coupe
des Yvelines après seulement quelques
minutes de jeu les eaux-villois en rose
manque l'ouverture du score sur cette
action
un électrochoc pour les élans courtois
qui évoluent en D2 de district ils
prennent le contrôle du jeu et se
procure les meilleurs occasions de cette
première période ils auraient pu se
retrouver en supériorité numérique mais
le gardien de où il ne se fera pas
expulser sur cette action
et récoltera un carton jaune le score la
pose 0 à 0 bon après c'est une décision
de l'arbitre c'est comme ça il faut
l'accepter
c'est un fait de jeu pour revenir sur
des saisons arbitrales mais pas carton
rouge moi j'ai pas les images donc je
sais pas on s'en sort plutôt bien parce
que ça selon l'interprétation de
certains arbitres si c'est rouge c'est
compréhensible au retour les vestiaires
et l'encours pousse et obtient un
penalty ne sera pas marqué par le numéro
quelques minutes plus tard sur ce centre
le but est refuser aux élans courtois
pour un hors-jeu les bleus et blancs ne
réussiront pas à marquer c'est
finalement Houilles qui s'impose grâce à
ce but 1 à 0 ce sera le score final on a
vu que il y avait la place quand même
parce que on a on a on a bien joué on
les a on les a maintenu dans le dans le
jeu on était à leur niveau et on aurait
pu on aurait pu marquer ce but un match
de coupe donc pas facile aujourd'hui
malgré la petite division d'écart qui
est entre les deux clubs après bon sort
le match coupe on sait très bien que ce
soit Coupe de France coupe peu importe
c'est l'état d'esprit
l'envie déjà de vouloir gagner ce match
parce que sur un match tout est possible
direction des huitièmes de finale pour
Houilles le prochain tour de la coupe
des Yvelines est programmé le dimanche 8
janvier 2023 le tirage au sort aura lieu
le 12 décembre prochain
où et qui pourrait affronter les Mureaux
de lime et Conflans
Montigny-le-Bretonneux molois Chambourcy
auberge en ville ou encore plaisir ce
sont les équipes qualifiées pour le
prochain tour prochain tour donc à venir
dans quelques semaines dans les Yvelines
on parle toujours de football de
championnat national 2 voici repart de
l'avant après trois matchs sans victoire
laisse Poissy dirigée par l’emblématique
président Olivier sevesu qui a gagné ce
samedi soir le club des Vinois s'est
imposé face à la réserve de Caen une
victoire qui fait du bien au classement
les pistes et sont actuellement à la
deuxième place avec 22 points en 10
journées on continue avec la Route du
Rhum Louis Burton le rambolitain a
abandonné mais il reste encore un
Versailles invinois en course
Eric Bellion le versaillé est engagé sur
cette édition 2022 dans la catégorie
Moka sur son bateau comme un seul homme
powerhead by Altavia le navigateur de 46
ans est encore à la 22e place du
classement même place que la semaine
dernière il vise un top 15 à la fin de
la course afin de se préparer pour le
prochain Vendée Globe et ça paraît de
plus en plus compliqué il devrait
arriver dans la semaine le premier
raymoka ce lundi à 7h51 c'était Thomas
Royan et dans la version virtuelle de la
Route du Rhum on est tout proche
d'arriver également dans la rédaction de
TV 78 personnellement je vais arriver
dans la nuit entre 3h et 4h du matin je
vais mettre le réveil qui va remporter
la Route du Rhum en rédaction du rugby à
présent Michael dans le championnat de
régional une l'Union rugby centre 78 à
goûter à la défaite ce dimanche l'équipe
c'est inclinée contre le CO multisport
Bagneux rugby sur le score le 13 à 10
une défaite qui n'arrange pas et 50
chinois ils se font dépasser au
classement par leur adversaire du jour
et son 4e égalité après cette journée le
basket et le championnat de National 3
belle victoire de Trappes ce samedi soir
sur son parquet face à Paris Basket à
venir les Trappistes l'ont emporté 84 à
76 après ce résultat le scrap et 6e du
championnat de National 3 après 10
journées disputés la montée l'objectif
fixé en début de saison va être
compliqué à attendre on joue également
ce week-end sur les terrains de handball
masculin parce que les féminines sont en
ce moment en trêve avec l'euro en
National trop à plaisir les clés à
réaliser une belle performance ce
dimanche à domicile les joueurs de
Benjamin modeste se sont imposés 28 à 24
devant leur supporter face à l'Union
Sportive Dreux Vernouillet handball de
son côté où il le vésiné carrière c'est
un clinique 33 à 27 façade cher
bourgeoise je mange au classement à
plaisir les clés et 6e et où il le
Vésinet carrière et septième vous
montrer les muscles peut-être pour
terminer ses résultats sportifs ce qu'on
va parler de culturisme
que Muriel
au championnat du monde de culturisme
naturel à Prague en République tchèque
la culturiste de 50 ans a été sacrée
vice-championne du monde à deux reprises
et elle a également emporté quatre
médailles de bronze au total si podium
dans 6 catégories elle est plutôt
satisfaite un de ses résultats même si
la médaille d'or n'est pas au bout bravo
à Muriel bauvillain pour ses résultats
merci nickel on continuera à la suivre
aussi continuer dans cette émission à
parler de sport et de parler plus
précisément de tennis on vous lisez tout
à l'heure le tournoi international BNP
Paris Yvelines Witcher tournament sera
organisé de ce jeudi 24 ce dimanche 27
novembre c'est à Feucherolles dans les
Yvelines alors pour parler de ce tournoi
deux invités sont avec nous ils sont
revenus en plateau leurs moraux qui est
directrice de ce tournoi également
Jean-François metek et secrétaire
général du Comité des Yvelines de tennis
vous en parler un peu tout à l'heure
pourquoi organiser un tournoi
international de tennis fauteuil tout
simplement parce que le comité des
Yvelines est engagé dans des différentes
actions sociétales et typiquement le
paratellis est notamment le tennis en
fauteuil on fait partie on est en plus
centre d'entraînement pour ce qu'on
appelle le groupe la relève Paris 2024
où on a des athlètes à la phare tels que
Pauline Déroulède Olivier Langlois ou
Anthony Bocquet qui sont en plus des non
seulement ce sont des Franciliens mais
surtout des vicinois donc voilà ça c'est
un intérêt pour nous bien sûr de mettre
en avant le département et donc au-delà
du haut niveau des sportifs valides
qu'on peut avoir ben là on est on est
typiquement dans l'inclusion des
personnes en situation de handicap avec
avec des événements phares et se
tournant international évidemment on
fait partie de Pauline Déroulède juste
qui sera la figure de prou mais qui
seront les autres participants on est
sur une version internationale tout à
fait alors il y a plusieurs nations
étrangères bien sûr qui vont être
présentés les USA la Suède le Nigéria
notamment
Pauline et figure de poux chez les chez
les filles on devrait avoir aussi
Guilhem Laget qui est un autre
prétendant titre chez des garçons 16
joueurs chez les garçons lui jouait chez
les filles voilà donc ça va être une
belle une belle affiche
qu'il y aura bon niveau sur sur les
cours est-ce qu'on verra du spectacle
bien sûr et donc on vous invite tous à
venir ce week-end l'entrée gratuite pour
voir ces joueurs c'est très
spectaculaire vous verrez en particulier
même sur le puisqu'il y aura du simple
et du double et c'est très spectaculaire
de voir de la manière ou ils évoluent
sur nos installations pour compléter ce
que disait alors effectivement ce nous
avons souhaité organisé ce type de
tournoi ça va dans le prolongement dans
notre structure d'entraînement dit la
relève ou Pauline Anthony et s'entraîne
tous les jours comité il faut savoir que
c'est la seule structure en France c'est
unique c'est notre structure et ça va
leur c'est on les prépare pour parler
2024 puisqu'ils ont un objectif de Paris
2024 avec Pauline effectivement qui est
faire de lance de notre structure et ce
genre de tournoi les aides dans leur
préparation pour l'objectif Paris 2024
on peut parler d'un tournoi de de
préparation pour ces Jeux paralympiques
Jeux Olympiques Jeux paralympiques qui
vont arriver qui sont dans toutes les
têtes c'est vraiment une préparation
tout à fait dans leur dans leur
préparation ils ont encore deux ans pour
pour évoluer mais ça fait partie de de
d'une préparation effectivement pour
parler 2024 pour nos trois athlètes que
les étrangers justement viennent dans
dans les Yvelines pour préparer ces Jeux
Olympiques c'est Jeux paralympiques de
je ne sais pas mais en tout
dans dans les mêmes tournois donc il y
avait un tournoi l'Open du Loiret la
semaine dernière il y a pas mal de
joueurs qui ont participé à cette open
qu'on va retrouver à Feucherolles la
semaine enfin cette semaine donc voilà
c'est un mine de rien microcosme aussi
les athlètes surtout chez des filles
sont sont moins nombreuses effectivement
donc elle se connaissent toutes il y a
certaines revanche à prendre mais je
pense que le titre devrait être français
quand même chez les chez les messieurs
et chez les femmes cette année en tout
cas on l'espère ce serait est-ce que
vous avez pu échanger avec Pauline des
roulettes dans quel état d'esprit
est-elle alors la tire la lumière sur ce
tournoi mais ce qu'elle est venue aussi
pour pour le remporter on imagine que
oui bah oui bien sûr
comme elle disait exactement en fait
elle joue à la maison donc c'est vrai
que elle s'est posée la question avec sa
coach de participer ou non à ce tournoi
là et pour elle évidemment il n'était
pas question qu'elle soit absente de
cette de ce tournoi donc on aura le
plaisir de la voir avec nous et de et de
l'avoir joué vous la sentez progresser
Jean-François Mettet Pauline Déroulède
de tournoi en tournoi d'année en année
bien sûr puisque bon
de ces trois ans trois ans que c'est
mieux
pour par son accident elle s'est
retrouvé donc en fauteuil et bien sûr
puisque maintenant les numéros en
français ça fait deux ans de suite qui a
gagné le championnat de France oui elle
a une progression elle est partie de de
nos enfin de vierge de ce de cette de ce
sport et aujourd'hui numéro 1 française
les temps forts bon il y aura les matchs
forcément du 24 au 27 il y a le tirage
au sort pour commencer c'est un peu le
l'événement pour lancer officiellement
le tournoi tirage au sort mercredi soir
voilà avec
on espère des belles affiches annoncées
ensuite mercredi évidemment accueille
aussi de la plupart des joueurs alors
certains sont déjà arrivés d'autres
arriveront uniquement mercredi d'autres
vont encore arriver jeudi très tôt avant
le début de la compétition donc c'est
toute une organisation qui représente
essentiellement sur des bains et
quelques salariés mais c'est aussi un
message important c'est que le
langagement bénévole prend tout son sens
aussi dans l'organisation de ce type
d'événement on est à peu près 20
bénévoles à
œuvrer aux côtés des de salariés du
comité et c'est vraiment un temps fort
dans la vie dans la vie du bénévole dans
la saison dans la saison sportive donc
pour y assister si on veut voir ce
tournoi est-ce que c'est gratuit est-ce
qu'il faut prendre ces places à l'avance
comment ça comment ça se passe
et vous serez tous et bienvenue
peut-être pour parler des autres
événements les autres grands événements
à venir pour le comité de tennis des
Yvelines alors un événement qui nous
tient à cœur aussi ça sera donc le
dernier weekend de janvier où nous
allons organiser puisque ça fait deux
années de suite malheureusement qui sont
annulés suite à la crise sanitaire et
donc on a de nouveau l'organisation de
la ce qu'on appelle la Wilton Cup
championnat d'Europe pour les jeunes
filles de 12 ans qui auront lieu donc
avec une nation dont la France et donc
c'est aussi un événement qui nous tient
à coeur et que nous allons organiser
donc ça sera le dernier week-end de
septembre
un dernier mot Michel peut-être oui
est-ce que ce tournoi international que
vous allez organiser va s'inscrire aussi
dans le temps il y a une première
édition cette année mais est-ce que vous
voulez l'accueillir l'année prochaine et
encore dans 10 ans peut-être alors tout
à fait c'est même on est même un peu
ambitieux mais bon c'est le propre des
sportifs c'est de vouloir aller toujours
plus loin et donc pour nous l'idée c'est
de se développer aussi et de monter dans
la hiérarchie des tournois
internationaux évidemment pour cela ben
ça nécessitera d'autres soutien alors on
a des beaux soutiens aujourd'hui un la
BNP Paribas évidemment nos instances de
tutelles d'autres partenaires privés
mais l'organisation d'un tournoi de
grade supérieure nécessitera aussi
d'aller chercher d'autres d'autres
partenaires voilà donc à suivre
Merci à VOUS Laure Moreau merci
Jean-François Mettet d'être venu parler
de ce tournoi international de tennis
fauteuil qui a lieu donc de ce jeudi à
ce dimanche c'est à Feucherolles bien
sûr dans les Yvelines
[Musique]